[Música]
ae
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ai meu deus como é que o começo tanto
tempo de namoro explodiu ea york que
aceite meu canal turma vocês olha só
quem está aqui de novo neste canal em
vai meu deus onde arrumou na mala cada
uma na mala que eu fazer show na europa
e eu estou indo amanhã com a europa no
caso está sendo hoje quando vocês estão
assistindo foi lançado o vídeo já devo
estar lá tô no caso aqui não é que eu
estou gravando em casa mas quando você
está assistindo eu já tô amanhã assim
amanhã eu fui para amsterdã e no dia 9
de novembro eu tenho um show em amsterdã
na holanda perde novembro milão na
itália 11 de novembro o show juric na
suíça 12 de novembro o show em londres
na inglaterra 13 de novembro pelo chão
país na van e 14 de novembro o show em
dublin na irlanda e 1790 um show em
divinópolis minas gerais e aí eu cheguei
no brasil como a preparação para o meu
bebê exatamente meu dvd no dia 2 de
dezembro jeneci arena no rio de janeiro
ou a gravação do meu especial que esse
show que eu já venho fazendo há um ano
que não é do rio e vai poder beber vai
sair do seu estado do acre rio grande do
sul depois do amazonas leva a bandeira
do seu estado que eu quero representar
todo mundo lá ingressos para todos os
shows estão nesse site aqui tá e
tampouco dá para ver né com uma visível
estou um pouco avantajado no topo no
espaço demais na terra já comecei a
fazer eu comecei que botar um emagrecido
poder ver dvd passada também xuxa eu
quero a paz nesse dvd vou ficar um pouco
isto tem um efeito mais remédio ou falar
sintomas que remete a quicar que esse
remédio aqui ele puxa o óleo bruto como
ele pega gordura e tocar a gordura foi
[__] sensacional sensacional e débito
enquanto usa que vai cagar tudo olha o
tanto de óleo que sai na merda fala
minha nossa senhora parece que fritar os
6 pastel no meu clube é sério é o óleo
mesmo que fica liso tá tomando banho
lavar o compasso de trigo de do sem
querer a gente gosto um pouco eu falei
já sei o que vou fazer vou fazer mais
exercícios eu reduzo a comida ou fazer
exercícios
aí eu fui pra casa do meu sogro por luís
o pai dela o pessoal os amigos dela os
meus amigos foi o que foi
a fazenda lá joga bola só o filé lugar
bonito tal não sei que em tal vento dr
[__] buscheta ea bola veio toca pra
mim p mosquito do [__] macho começou
a aparecer tanto busque tu e eu vou
falar com vocês assim tem poucas coisas
que tenho ódio nome poucas coisas me
tiram do sério bom uísque eu sou um cara
que agora natureza falar a verdade o há
pouco que massa e se essa árvore 100
anos a itaqui legal ao sol se pondo
paulo o psol aquelas coisas meu deus
ararazul temos que proteger a natureza
linda só agora falou e mosquito
os filhos de merda eu quero que morra
veja bem não estou falando de música
música eu tenho raiva também porque
nojento ocorra mosca como boston ray
muzyka da raiva porque ela ela tenta
gente a moça não sabe pousar eu nunca vi
uma moça ainda assim os fãs já dar um
rasante pousa aqui não era bem vai ter
11 um pouso na mosca é a desgraça inseto
é a desgraça só fala não insetos
precisão por causa do ciclo da vida que
porque que a mosca um alimento com o
sapo [__] sapo outra que parou de
sapos apa negócio não tem nem explicar
acho que eu estava fazendo o animal foi
fazendo foi fazendo sobre o negócio
pegou os negócios sobrou juntou juntou
esse que eu vou chamar de sá
eita botei leite mantém peito saiu nas
costas nada a ver o sapo a mãe tem que
ter o sapo que faz parte do ciclo da
vida porque o sapo é alimento para cobra
pensa assim
[__] a cobra morra agora todas não
estou nem aí pra pobre a não gostar meu
deus do céu
só consegui entender rápido música rap
mosquito a minha tão grande que ele me
fez ter raiva do sap da copa não tem
nada a ver com ele eu nunca encontrei um
sapo nem uma cobra que me fizesse mal
algum ponto estão de boa na vida deles
tem aquele sabe que fica na fazenda
gritando nem pensa que a gente sabe que
está andando de noite a fazer essas
coisas mas sempre houve mortes após
escutar assim o sapo gente boa moça papo
inseto e geral eu não botei os bon ao
mosquito é um lixo abelha futebol porque
a melhor chique mosca como boston abelha
tomar coca abreu e fred quer saber de
cabeça num
um agogô quinha gabeira também se
estende pela coca-cola roda tanto moda
tanto tanto cobra da gente desiste a
percepção que a gente perde o
refrigerante abelha agora o mosquito não
não serve
morra todos hoje se puder agora a
formiga a formiga não sei o que eu sinto
pela fome que a família me traz um
sentimento de bipolaridade que afirmei a
trai a confiança da gente a fome está
andando a gente acha bonitinho lo é
bonitinha formiga caminhando ela mora a
filha da [__] 11 me mordeu cá e isso é
triste que o amava ela alguns segundos
até e mordeu matei formiga massa que a
formiga é inteligente a família
inteligente uma família morre afogado no
suco e morreu afogada cpc [__] vai
servir de exemplo para as outras outro
bonde envolvê e vão voltar não vão
quando se vota e óleo copa em 12 e
deixar quando volta tem 36 quando cai a
formiga do copo de suco em pó mandava
bebê que é bom para a vista magnífica é
bom para a gente eu chamei você não
saiba realmente um pouco de sentir que
eu nunca vi o filme de oxigênio onde
fugiu caminhando só você parar de falar
comigo que foi ela procura minha lente
caiu uma coisa que eu acho interessante
quando formei uma folga de suco é que a
gente tem nojo de gente sabe que assumir
com barata como sujeira como merda
também aí quando morre fica olhando
assim pra cá e honra também nomeou sul
só que você não liga para a contaminação
do sul a gente liga é para não engolir a
formiga também tivemos aqui o formiga
por canta pode rodar até a formiga que
encostar na margem assim aí aí eu me
sinto à vontade para beber o suco
metonímia tentei fazer isso também bata
[__] que pariu barata é a desgraça que
eu dei barata tenho medo da bata o
problema quer barata da minha casa
parece que ela malha tomou próprio
gigante um dia apareçam barato aqui em
casa junto eu juro pra você a barata
usava boné pi tão grande que era barata
quando aparece a barca que faz mais
impulso humano sou inteligente aqui
nessa por sou eu que mando aqui eu vou
lhe pegar o chinelo de boa e vou matar
essa batata dignamente acabar até
desgraça país que lê a mente da gente
que você tá aí pra pegar o chinelo ela
se mexe um pouco a gente automaticamente
paralisa agora tá aqui parada sei que um
dia vou pegar o chinelo faça você está
empregado é facinho automaticamente onde
você consegue fazer acham outra pessoa
tem casa passeando cleiton a liberar
janeiro álcool chega e fala assim
calma e fique de boa sou inteligente
essa [__] eu sou humano que vou pegar o
chinelo livro uma tarde na mente abrigou
do nada e nunca consegue prever quando a
bancada vai votar você pode tá de boa de
busca assim talibã ela abre volvo
a filha da [__] e não importa quantas
vezes ela voa o susto mesmo bateu na
parede do nada fui merda de merda da
[__] interessa do vôo da barata que mais
que ela mesmo confeccionou as asas em
casa ela colou nas costas no fez teste
nenhum dano sabella vou fazer uso e até
aqui do nada só me falou [__] que pariu
foi chamar os amigos amigos ou maior que
é não ter como arcar com china vai ter 5
a partir do nada ela aparece na
geladeira mas do nada do tão do nada que
eu acho que ela não vou aceitar ela
transporta ela partiu assim aparece
melhor pagar ladeira falou calma que eu
sou humano nessa [__] sou eu que sou
inteligente aqui nessa merda pegar o
chinelo de boa e vou matar ela
dignamente eu vou pegar o chinelo ela se
mexe o pleito calma que eu que sou
humano nessa [__] eu vou pegar e aquele
china vão matar ela dignamente ela
voltasse méxico cliente fica paradinho
assim em packs fica de boa tabela b
o marcos chega a falar alguma de vocês
sempre de bois ou 2 bastado eu que sou
humano nessa [__] inteligente vou pegar
o chinelo ela volta de jean amiga para
atleta de base do armário a galera que
tá na cozinha batalha mas quer uma
polícia dando bakulejo bandido mata a
bola a passar pouco mais próxima da [__]
praça maika perfume perfume na amora é
do milan e teve de tudo fica calmo chama
mais gente este jeito a cozinha e tenta
com chinelo tenta comparar vassoura
perfume para ver se mata desgraçada
ninguém consegue matar aquela desgraça
ela vai embora ainda mais cheirosa não
tem nada para ter mais ódio no mundo do
que a muriçoca muriçoca pernilongo como
shaman em outro lugar o que merda é um
milagre só que o mosquito da dengue da
série b problema e só pra mim não é
suportar ela não é ter raiva eu tenho é
ódio eu declaro que hoje tem um ódio por
isso eu confesso vos solte pessoa que eu
vejo a formiga se afogando eu salvo foi
meio à fauna foi meu deus
bota o dedinho assim espera formigo
subir no meu dedo eo leva até a fifa
assim vai embora fome para alimentar sua
família
eu te amo fome agora muricy só teve um
quadro de desgaste ea culpa a vaga
parem de roubar eu sou do piauí ceapi
falar que o animal se adapta às
condições muriçoca de casa gigante
imenso b para ser um peixe espada se eu
chegasse com mata mosquito dessa sim ela
levantava o braço para passar no sul vai
se a capivara desgraça usar ventilador
no meu quarto e vi para nada muriçocas
sentava na frente do ventilador para
ficar cantando voz de robô kiko matar no
tapa de ser um murro tinha vez que eu
perdi ainda tem uma técnica muito [__]
para não vir mais por isso que na minha
casa eu quero ensinar você pra que nunca
vá muriçoca mas na sua casa fácil comuns
só começa a me chutar em vez de eu matar
eu deixo ela me chupar o fisco estou
dormindo deixando chupar o máximo que
ela pudesse encher a barriga ela vai
embora que ela faz ela avisa a galera
dela galera sangue de graça linha embora
tomar sangue pra [__]
como é que eu vou morrer eu vou morrer
mas eu acho para você o que é que eu
faço eu saiba não ver a galera o que
acontece não tem ninguém a muriçoca fica
de mentirosa que acontece se estabiliza
o grupo eu criei uma intriga dentro
deles que tem despertado pelo menos um
limite de velocidade talvez eu não
tivesse tanta rapidez que se passa
voando meu ataque de botton entregando
os ônibus que passa a ser lei carai the
ronettes se você tiver postado o vídeo
hoje não esquece de clicarem gostei aqui
tá os é que viu pelo facebook eu sigo
isso no facebook clique em curtir lacaz
e se esquecem de fazer isso que curtirá
não se esquece você está no twitter eu
vi lá pelo twitter volta lá no post da
rt lapena mais gente 20 escreve o canal
não perdendo um vídeo novo tamo junto é
nóis iptu e do pt que fica na cat